self-driving cars are just around their
next bend
on this test track are two existing
production models automatically steering
braking and crucially avoiding each
other but under current rules the driver
has to be in control
the big change now being written into
the highway code allows the car to take
over well in this vehicle it's telling
you to put your hands back on the wheel
because this is an assisted driving
vehicle with an autonomous vehicle
you'll be able to take your hands off
the wheel and your eyes off the road and
look at the screen
and watch tv
you won't be able to use a mobile tablet
or read a book the logic being you might
miss the car's instructions to take over
but the rules could change as fast as
the technology does it's a big jump to
go between the driver driving and the
vehicle driving so these systems are
only going to work at low speed in
queueing traffic only about 37 miles an
hour and only in queueing traffic on
certain motorways but the systems will
get better
the highway code is still being drafted
but out on the highway itself the test
will be whether it clearly defines where
drivers and vehicle manufacturers
liabilities begin and end
it's important that whenever we have new
technology the liabilities are looked at
very carefully uh and ultimately it's
important that drivers know what they're
responsible for manufacturers know what
they're responsible for and actually
that we are all striving towards the
same goal which is to make our roads
fundamentally much safer
if the legalities are clear insurers
support automated driving because it
could reduce accidents leading car
makers have said they'll accept
liability if the vehicle is driving at
the time of a crash
look no hands speak to the automotive
industry and they'll tell you that the
technology for automated driving is
effectively already here
the government now hopes its new highway
code is foot for purpose so the question
is is the driving public ready
absolutely not why not
because i don't think the technology's
advanced far enough
for me it would be an absolute no if
we're not letting people use their
mobile phones why would letting them
watch telly even if they're sitting in
traffic you still need to be aware of
your surroundings and what you're what
you're doing you've got a car that that
potentially can take you from a to b and
you don't have to put any energy or
effort into it why wouldn't you
it's the future we all know that
that's why they're doing all the work
they're doing like the idea or not
self-driving cars are just about to
shift themselves up a gear the first
fully automated car could go on sale in
the uk as early as this autumn tom clark
sky news oxfordshire